do you still love star wars now the same
way you did when you first saw it in the
theater or wherever you were absolutely
i consider myself just a huge star wars
fan i i i love star wars i
am wildly
not objective about star wars uh and you
know it's interesting from a you know i
i
i try to be objective about star wars
but i find myself um
loving it anyway and i you know i i go
back and and i look at star wars and i i
you know i read i recently read the
script of episode one of phantom menace
and
may have been the worst script i've ever
read
like just it's just a really
bad script in my opinion it was just
terrible it's terrible
i still love the movie i still love the
movie uh and it's interesting i think
you know you look at some artistic
decisions you know how you watch black
swan and then you see how the george
lucas turned natalie portman into a bad
actress like how did that even like you
and mcgregor liam neeson and natalie
portman how do you turn those people
into and samuel jackson how do you how
do you turn them into bad actors uh that
are wooden and stiff like that's that's
hard to do would he did that they like
they weren't that great think of the
artistic choice of the second death star
in uh in return of the jedi i was
thinking about that the other day uh you
have the death star in in the first
movie and then you get to the third
movie and the and the and then the
central plot is around uh a second death
star that that in today's market i think
would be just like laughed at and people
would say it's lazy riding and doesn't
doesn't make a lot of sense
but i love it i love i love the original
movies i love the prequel trilogy i love
the new movies that were a mess in a lot
of ways uh i feel like the rise of
skywalker was three movies shoved into
two hours and it was pacing issues and
all this stuff but i still love it and
that's i think the magic of star wars is
that
star wars doesn't have to be perfect it
it it taps into
this
youthful
uh
whimsy this this uh
this your imagination and and things
just take over and and and it it takes
you to this childlike place where
you don't have to be objectively
filmmakery when you watch star wars
right and and uh you know of course i
want the movies to be good and of course
you want the craft to be great um
but you know star wars is star wars and
and and i'm still a huge fan i'm a fan
of what they're doing you know on the
streaming stuff with the mandalorian and
everything else um but uh um you know
for me
star wars is is is is like
an old box
and some like an old empty box and me as
a dad i have a seven year old and a and
a six month old and uh it's interesting
like i'll look at an empty box as an old
empty box
but a kid looks at that empty box and it
becomes a spaceship or it becomes a
carriage or it becomes a tank or it
becomes a castle or becomes all of those
in the course of 25 minutes
right
i think
star wars is like
that old empty box
to
to some
filmmakers and writers and
artists and critics they say
that's that's there's nothing special
about that that's not great i don't get
it it's just a box but for me when i
look at star wars i look at at it like
the seven-year-old looking at the empty
box you know no that's not a box that's
that's that's that's an airplane right
that's a spaceship and uh and and it
takes a different lens to look through
it and so you know i am i am unabashed
of of uh of my love for epi uh for for
uh
uh the last jedi right which is the most
divisive star wars film ever ryan
johnson's uh uh you know episode nine um
i loved it i didn't love everything
about it
but i loved it
that i loved uh i loved uh um
the rise of skywalker i loved it did i
love everything about it of course not
do i love everything about about return
of the jedi of course not but i still
love the movie as a whole i think
we've the fandom has gotten to a point
of this
deconstructionism of of they people pick
on things and they say this doesn't you
know i mean think about
with game of thrones and you know game
of last season of game of thrones gave
us you know the battle battle of
winterfell gave us one of the most
dramatic interesting coolest episodes of
tv ever filmed ever in history and the
only thing people could talk about the
next day was the coffee cup they left in
the scene and because that's today's
thing like that's just the way the
internet is that's just the way twitter
is and and people like to deconstruct it
and say oh that's lazy or they drop they
they they they fumbled the landing or
whatever they didn't end it right uh jj
abrams didn't do this right he didn't
get this character right i don't like
how ryan johnson did luke skywalker in
this and they nitpick and nitpick and
yeah and you know
things you know things could be
different things aren't perfect and we
don't love everything but ultimately
you know i i'm i'm a fan and i love it
because it's just you know it's it's
escapism and and um you know and i try
honestly as a professional
and i think all of us professionals
understand
how difficult it is to make anything
and how like it's a miracle that any
movie ever gets made ever uh and so i've
i've learned to even look at
quote-unquote bad films and still
appreciate them like wow they actually
made that even though it's terrible and
i wasn't they didn't necessarily enjoy
it they still made it and the fact that
the the fact that you know that that
anything gets made i'm gonna appreciate
it and if i can't do better than that i
try not to criticize it uh
and say that's garbage or that's lazy or
whatever
again i don't love everything about it
but ultimately i look i look at i look
at the star wars films and and just
with with immense respect
for
how they've been able
to keep that ip alive over 60 years or
50 years however long it's been how much
they've been able to scale the brand how
long they've been able to sustain the
fan community and create the culture
that they have
to continue to to push artistic
boundaries of what they're doing with
the mandalorian and the volumetric
capture stage that they they built and
and uh just you know
the storytelling in the mandalorian what
they're doing what they're doing now
with all the crossover stuff that that
one on disney plus is absolutely
incredible you have somebody like a
character like ahsoka tano i'm gonna get
star wars nerdy for a second yeah but
you have a character like ahsoka tano
who is a character from the clone wars
animated series that they then pull into
a different animated series star wars
rebels that they then pull into a
live-action series of the mandalorian uh
and cast a live-action actress and now
gonna spin her off to her own
live-action series on disney plus what
they're doing from a trans me in a trans
media sense it's just really super
interesting and and how they revived the
star wars um they say revive
the star
it's not like it was dead but like the
way they brought star wars back in front
of culture with baby yoda
and and now we know as grosgu but but
ever like everybody was talking about
baby yoda just the cultural sensation of
baby yoda it's just really smart
interesting
choices that they make and especially
now start they just uh they have
something now called star wars visions
where they it's it's uh it's um
animated short films that are all done
created in the manga style uh so you
like uh japanese animation is all done
in with with manga creators uh telling
manga stories uh in the star wars
universe that are
very much catered to uh to a completely
new market a younger market a more
eastern market where star wars hasn't
been able to really get a foothold as a
brand very much and and and and it works
and it's good and it's in it and it's
it's powerful storytelling and um so i
appreciate them
as a fan i appreciate them as a
filmmaker and i appreciate them as
somebody who understands how to build
and sustain ip like the way they do it
is just a master class on
on how to keep an engine like that
running and not just running but
thriving in the midst of
multiple multiple decades this really is
a tremendous thing and it all goes back
to how george lucas
created and built the whole thing it's
really like he he approached it in a
unique way and they've continued to keep
that going
do you think dividing the fandom is by
design
i don't think it's by design i think
it's i think it's
a
byproduct of today's
toxic
fandom uh that is just a thing that that
goes on now um but i i think if you were
to criticize lucasfilm uh for something
it's
it's with the movies
they
they didn't listen to the fandom um not
saying that star wars movie the star
wars fans should decide what's in the
star wars movies um i'm i'm very much
certain that if star wars fans somehow
collectively decided what the next star
wars movie was going to be it would be
terrible uh
there is artistic integrity and autonomy
with the filmmakers but if you look at
somebody like kathleen kennedy kathleen
kennedy is she's an old school
filmmakers filmmaker she's an old school
filmmakers producer you know the the way
she
used to produce you know old you know
steven spielberg stuff
and
she's very much a filmmaker's producer
she likes to let the filmmakers
run and make great movies
and uh
and i think part of
the misstep of of the the latest trilogy
has been
in
her letting the filmmakers kind of run
with their own
visions and the lego blocks don't fit
together with the trilogy as well and
not really being in tune
with
the fandom and and and what the fandom
you know the directions and what the
expectations are and uh and being able
to set the expectations with with the
fandom and and not that you can please
everybody of course you can't but um but
uh
in some with something like star wars
you just can't approach it in the way
you would in the other movie it's just a
whole other organism that you have to
understand the fans are part of the
process now and uh and setting
expectation
and avoiding cognitive dissonance is a
really important thing with uh with with
understanding how fandoms work so if i
if if um
if if i was if i were to go to
the south of france for a vacation
and and i get there and it's uh overcast
and rainy and cold and super expensive
and everybody's grouchy and and not very
nice i would come back from that
vacation very upset and frustrated
wasn't a great vacation
but if i go to new york city
and it's overcast and cold and rainy and
really expensive and everybody's grouchy
guess what that's new york city like i'm
not like i'm not frustrated that a bit
that's the new york city experience the
difference is what's your expectation
and so if if i have the expectation it's
going to be warm and bright and sunny
and everybody's going to be sweet and
nice and it's the opposite of that
that's where frustration kicks in
because of cognitive dissonance and so
managing expectation of audiences and
and and letting them know
the direction that we're going and some
of the things we're trying to achieve
and and and letting them have a voice
and and and and making them part of the
conversation and and and helping shape
some sort of expectation in their mind
not saying plot points or things like
that or big reveals i'm sorry it's just
general direction that that the
franchise is heading uh that
conversation is super important to have
with fandoms today and that's something
that lucasfilm and kathleen kinley
didn't do when it came to the the the
sequel trilogy as they call it and and
you and you see now all of a sudden you
know when when uh you know i think
everybody was on board for force awakens
but then when ryan johnson did the last
jedi and luke skywalker didn't act like
people thought luke skywalker should act
and there were some choices that were
made that were surprising and didn't go
that and then then all of a sudden rises
skywalker went in some different
directions
that started to divide the fandom and uh
and some people loved it some people
hated it and we they all couldn't agree
and
but but there wasn't enough community
building i think they just took the
community for granted i think they said
as long as we give them a star wars
movie everything will work out and it
just you know it didn't didn't work but
that being said
you know kathleen kennedy gave us the
mandalorian kathleen kennedy gave us
rogue one which i think is one of the
best star wars movies ever made uh uh
kathleen kennedy has is you know giving
us uh
she brought in john favreau for for the
mandalorian she's the the book of boba
fett she's overseeing all that like
katherine kennedy i think has done more
good things than
the bad things it just so happens that i
think the misstep was on the biggest
stage with the new trilogy because star
wars really is built around trilogies
and uh that's the legacy of star wars
and so you have to nail those uh they i
think we could fumble some disney plus
series and the fans would gripe about it
but you can't fumble the the the the uh
um the trilogy and i'm not saying it's
complete fumble but it wasn't
it wasn't as good as it should have been
from a from a from a trilogy standpoint
there should have been uh she should
have made sure that there was
there was a creative vision and a
creative plan
that was that was in place before they
even started the first movie and they
were able to see that through so there
would be lego blocks that connected in
the best possible way
make sure the community was on board and
understood the direction they were going
to they were going in to avoid the
cognitive dissonance and that didn't
happen so that being said the movie is
still wildly successful but but
ultimately it created this division the
fan base
but the mandalorian kind of brought them
all back together and so even though you
may hate last jedi and i love last jedi
we can all high five on baby yoda right
and uh and so that's been that's been i
think a really good thing for the fandom
is is the mandalorians kind of brought
it all back so
should star wars ever make another
trilogy oh absolutely i think they
should make 100 more trilogies as long
as the market
it will bear it as long as star wars
fans want more star wars movies
absolutely if star wars fans don't want
more star wars movies then then no right
the market should decide whether they
should make more or whether they
shouldn't make more i i would love i
would love more right uh and i think
we're gonna i think we're gonna we're
gonna see more i think we're gonna see
stand-alone movies and i think we're
gonna see trilogies i think the
trilogies will be approached differently
uh moving forward but patty jenkins is
coming in you know she did wonder woman
both the wonder woman movies she's doing
a rogue squadron film which should be
great uh kevin feige is going to be
producing uh a uh
a star wars film taekwontiti is uh
writing his own star wars movie ryan
johnson uh
uh from what i've read still has uh star
wars uh a trilogy that they're gonna
allow him to do which will probably be
super divisive and
but i think if you give him a trilogy
that's just his it works a lot better
right uh especially after this what
we're seeing like his success in knives
out and things like that since then i
think has has changed his star power a
little bit to where i think people trust
trust him a little bit more with it uh
than maybe they did before at least they
should because knives out is great and
knives out too should be great as well
i'm a big ryan chancellor friend if you
go back to brick and things like that
he's just great um but but yeah
absolutely 100 they should they should
continue to make trilogies they can they
should continue to make standalone they
should continue to do animation they
should uh should continue to do live
action series
games uh
board games video games novels uh what
they're doing right now in in the
publishing space is super super super
impressive with what they call the high
republic um uh
the high republic part of the universe
which is thousands of years before the
prequel trilogy uh you go back to the
the days where the jedi were like the um
the the wild west sheriff's uh you know
in in sort of this this really rough
part of the galaxy and and uh they they
have coordinated with multiple authors
and multiple comic creators and multiple
novelists and and uh and they all have
have worked out this tremendously
publishing plan where they're where
they're publishing adult novels why a
novels junior novels comic books that
all tie in together to create one big
publishing experience that then is going
to spin into a live-action show for
disney plus that's going to be uh called
the acolyte which is going to be set in
the high republic era which they just
also announced a new video game that's
going to be set in the uh the knights of
the old republic supposedly set in the
similar time um and
uh and probably then probably become the
new trilogy i think part of the the the
problem with the sequel trilogy
outside of the lego blocks is not
fitting together because the plan wasn't
installed is you're dealing with legacy
characters that everybody cares about
luke skywalker and han solo and princess
leia and chewbacca and so all of a
sudden everybody has ideas of how those
characters should go and how and what we
should do with them you can't kill that
one but you should kill that one things
like that i think i think any new
trilogy
needs to
unhitch from those legacy characters and
establish new characters and uh news
stories in different parts of the galaxy
uh dealing with different things and so
you don't have all that legacy baggage
that's why i think the mandalorian
worked is because it was it was it
didn't have to deal with any of those
legacy characters and we all like okay
we don't have any expectations anymore
of of how luke skywalker's story should
end we can all just
enjoy this new ride together and so i
think
i i think that will probably be the way
of a new trilogy um
but but who knows i mean right i mean
who knows the way it'll go i mean if
star wars is sort of built around this
idea of uh of of pulling in you know the
crossover of different things and taking
minor characters from the background of
this one scene and a new hope and now
we're gonna make that a major character
in the mandalorian and and that's cool
for fandoms and there's this very
incestuous approach to star wars which
maybe is not the best word to use but
maybe is the right word since
luke and leia actually kiss and then you
find out their brother and sister which
is all again one of those weird things
that we just love star wars so we
overlook uh but uh but but it's very uh
very connected and the way they dine
with the way lucas always dynamically
connected all the stuff and the
lucasfilm with the with what they call
the story group which is the the team
that oversees the connection between all
the different uh video games and movies
and tv shows how it all works together
so if there will always be connection
and crossover but i think
moving past the legacy characters is
gonna
is gonna create it
create a more forgiving
uh perspective on it on a new trilogy uh
that they didn't have with the sequel
trilogy even though they had different
protagonists the fact that luke
skywalker was in there and han solo was
in there and you know jj killed han solo
uh in force awakens and it just like
freaked so many people out even though i
thought it was a kind of a powerful
interesting moment uh uh in the movie
really just made a lot of people mad
because they love han solo and they we
think they should never die
star wars fans are weird like that but
it but it's it's i think unhitching from
those characters is really gonna be the
way forward so uh i really look forward
to all the new content whether whether
it's it's it's
it's it's feature films or not what i do
think though is that they'll really
manage the windowing of the release of
the films it was getting to a point
where you know they were they were
releasing one a year
and uh that i think
was was difficult especially when you
put in the marvel movies in the mix uh
black panther and solo were released you
know just a few weeks apart and and you
know there there was some disney
cannibalization going on i think the way
forward for star wars movies is just
spacing them out more right especially
if you have the disney plus content and
the publishing content and the the game
content to kind of go between the movies
to help continue to feed the fan base
between those big releases
i think that's going to make them more
special and
because once you start kind of pumping
them out so much
they start to lose their shine a little
bit um and
especially when it comes to you know the
interconnected stories it's just it's
just
they become less special so windowing i
think will help